lots of academics got together to try
and shut down my project on ethics and
Empire which wasn't an invitation to
discussion it was a repression why
behave that way one explanation which I
think is plausible and I got this really
from Pascal Brooker the French Jesuit
educated philosopher it's a kind of
degenerate Christianity so Christians
believe that truly saintly virtuous
people are people who are deeply aware
of just how un virtuous they are there's
kind of paradox there that's a good
thing in many respects but it can be
perverted so the the is that some people
nowadays think that if I can declare
myself or my culture or my nation to be
uniquely
sinful it's a kind of perverse way of
retaining the moral High ground and
Brookner says this is what Europe's
doing Europe is no longer a superpower
doesn't Ru the world anymore but it
tries to be a moral superpower by saying
we are the worst oppressors ever in the
history of the world and no one did it
as bad as we did is a kind of virtue
signaling that makes us feel more
righteous because we are more
self-critical in